في يوم الثلاثاء ، سيلقي الرئيس بايدن
خطابه الأول أمام الجمعية العامة للأمم المتحدة
، ويأتي الخطاب في لحظة حاسمة في
رئاسة بايدن وسيكون له
تأثير خاص على كيفية النظر إليه في
الخارج بعد ما يقرب من ثمانية أشهر من
مشاهدة سياسات الخطاب والأزمات التي لدى
العديد من المراقبين الأجانب.
فوجئت حتى بالصدمة لاكتشاف أن
سياسة بايدن الخارجية في منطقة تلو الأخرى
هي استمرار لسياسة دونالد ترامب ، وأن
بعض هذا الاستياء من باراك أوباما هو نتيجة
للطريقة المفاجئة والأحادية الجانب
التي سحب بها بايدن القوات الأمريكية
من أفغانستان دبلوماسيًا ألمانيًا
أخبرني أنه من وجهة نظره ، تمت استشارة برلين
من قبل الإدارة الرابحة أكثر من
هذه ،
وبعض الإجراءات المحددة مثل
صفقة الغواصة الأمريكية البريطانية التي
أغضبت فرنسا ،
لكن المخاوف المتزايدة تتجاوز
أي حادثة واحدة ، أشار دبلوماسي أوروبي كبير
إلى ذلك  في التعامل مع
واشنطن في كل شيء بدءًا من اللقاحات
وحتى قيود السفر
كانت سياسات بايدن هي أمريكا الأولى في المنطق
بغض النظر عن الخطاب
الذي قاله سياسي كندي إنه إذا
اتبعت خطط بايدن لشراء أمريكا فهي في
الواقع أكثر حمائية من
سياسات ترامب على الرغم من انتقاده
لتعريفات ترامب مرارًا وتكرارًا ، فقد أبقى بايدن
جميعها تقريبًا في الواقع تم توسيع العديد منها
منذ معظم الإعفاءات إلى
لقد سُمح لهم بإنهاء صلاحية
الحلفاء الآسيويين الرئيسيين ، واستمروا في الضغط على بايدن
للعودة إلى الشراكة عبر المحيط الهادئ
التي أشاد بها كثيرًا عندما
تفاوضت إدارة أوباما عليها بدلاً من
ذلك ، تم وضع
مثال صارخ آخر على
سياسة بايدن الخارجية المفاجئة وهو الاتفاق النووي الإيراني.
الإنجازات البارزة
لإدارة أوباما
خلال حملته الانتخابية جادل بايدن
بأن انسحاب ترامب من تلك
الاتفاقية كان خطأً جوهريًا
وأنه كرئيس سينضم إليها بسرعة
طالما أن إيران ستنتقل أيضًا
إلى الامتثال
في أوائل عام 2019.
مستشار الأمن د  اعتبر
إعادة ترامب فرض عقوبات ثانوية
ضد طهران على أنها أحادية مفترسة ،
لكن منذ توليه منصبه
فشل بايدن في إحياء الصفقة وأبقى معظم
العقوبات على إيران بعد أن جادل منذ فترة طويلة
ضد محاولة إعادة التفاوض بشأن الصفقة ،
يقول مسؤولون بايدن الآن إنهم يريدون
إطالة هذه الصفقة وتعزيزها.
حتى الآن ، لم تنجح استراتيجية بايدن هذه ، فارتفع
مخزون إيران من
اليورانيوم المخصب من أقل من 300
كيلوغرام في 2018 بعد الصفقة إلى
حوالي
2500 كيلوغرام اليوم
أو النظر في السياسة تجاه كوبا
، كانت إدارة أوباما جريئة بما يكفي
لمعالجة واحدة من أكثر
الإخفاقات الصارخة فينا  السياسة الخارجية
بعد أن عزلت كوبا وفرضت عليها عقوبات
منذ عام 1960 لإحداث تغيير في النظام في
ذلك البلد ، عززت الولايات المتحدة
بدلاً من ذلك النظام الشيوعي في كوبا ،
فيدل كاسترو ، أثار القوميين
أكثر من خلال إلقاء اللوم على جميع مشاكل كوبا
على الحظر ، وبعيدًا عن
الإطاحة به ، انتهى به الأمر بالبقاء في
السلطة  أطول من أي زعيم غير ملكي
على هذا
الكوكب  مع إيران ، تم دفع تكلفة هذه السياسات
من قبل الناس العاديين ،
وبدأ أوباما في التخفيف من هذه السياسات
تجاه كوبا ترامب عكس مسار
بايدن.
كانت
إسرائيل هي الدولة الوحيدة التي صوتت مع
واشنطن
بايدن ، وكثيراً ما انتقد فريقه
ترامب بسبب هجومه على النظام الدولي القائم على القواعد ،
ولكن كيف يمكن للمرء إعادة بناء مثل هذا النظام
مع تبني الحمائية العارية من
جانب واحد عقوبات محدودة
الاستشارات وسياسات أمريكا الأولى
بشأن أشياء مثل اللقاحات وحتى السفر
عندما كنت عائدًا من أوروبا
الأسبوع الماضي ، قال موظف الخطوط الجوية البريطانية الذي قام
بفحصي بعصبية ، آمل أن
يكون لديك جواز سفر أمريكي ،
فقلت نعم ولكن سألت لماذا بدت مرتاحة للغاية
فأجابت يا  لقد جعل الأمريكيون من
دخول الأوروبيين إلى بلادهم كابوسًا
ويبدو أنه غير عادل لأننا نحن  لديها
معدلات تطعيم أعلى بكثير
ومستويات أقل بكثير من فيروس كورونا مما
تفعله ، وخلصت في سخطها إلى
أنه يبدو أن هذه الأيام أنتم
الأمريكيون تريدون معيارًا مزدوجًا
يساعدك بغض النظر عما يعتقده الآخرون
أنه لا يجب أن يكون بهذه الطريقة
يجب أن تكون أنانية ترامب  يمكن
لبايدن أن يستخدم المنبر للعودة
إلى جذوره العميقة باعتباره
أمميًا يفهم أن الدول لا
تتحالف ببساطة مع أمريكا بدافع الخوف أو
الرشاوى أو المخاوف الأمنية الضيقة
لأنها تفعل ذلك لأن أفضل رؤسائها
قد صاغوا واتبعوا سياسات
أنه بينما كنا دائمًا منتبهين لنا ، فقد
حاولت المصالح أيضًا بناء نظام دولي مفتوح
قائم على القواعد
يساعد الآخرين على الازدهار والازدهار
إذا واصل جو بايدن مساره الحالي على
الرغم من أن
المؤرخين قد ينظرون إليه يومًا
ما على أنه الرئيس الذي قام بتطبيع
السياسة الخارجية لدونالد ترامب